هذه الضربات اين تضع الحكومه العراقيه اي
في هذا
الحال الحكومه العراقيه يعني منذ منذ حرب
غزه تعاني اشد المعاناه خصوصا انها بين
مطرقه بين المطرقه
والسندان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والعمليات المستمره استهدفت الكثير من
النقاط العسكريه للحشد الشعبي وكذلك بعض
فصال المقاومه ومن جهه اخرى ايضا لديها
التزامات مع الولايات المتحده وكذلك
شركائها في العمليه
السياسيه الفصائل المقاومه ايضا ترى انه
هنالك تمادي واكثر من مره ك يعني اصبحوا
ضحيه هذه العمليات العسكريه وهي عاجزه على
ان تتخذ قرار ممكن ان يخفف عنها الحرج في
نهايه المطاف كما ذكرت ايضا حتى انه في ال
يعني لبيان من لكتائب حزب الله ذكرت انه
من اجل تخفيف الحرج عن الحكومه علقت هذه
العمليات ولا اعتقد انه سوف يتم تعليقها
الى ما لا نهايه هي ارادت ان تعطي فرصه
لان الحكومه ذهب باتجاه ان تشكل لجان
وبالفعل ذكرت ان هنالك لجان عسكريه مع
قيادات عسكريه امريكيه يبحثون اعاده النظر
بما يسمى بالتحالف الدولي وجدوى بقاءه
ايضا الاطار اتفاقيه الاطار الاستراتيجي
الموقعه بين بغداد والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وكيفيه الاستفاده منها الحكومه
ذهب بهذا الاتجاه طبعا الفصائل مؤيده لكن
هي تشكك بالنوايا الحقيقيه للاداره
الامريكيه وانها لا ترغب بالخروج لانه
لديها اهداف ايضا كما ذكر ضيفكم ان هنالك
جهات سياسيه ايضا هي ترغب ببقاء الولايات
المتحده لانها تعتقد ان وجود الولايات
المتحده في العراق ي يعتبر ضمانه سياسيه
لهذه الجهات السياسيه ومن هنا الوضع
السياسي منقسم كحاله وحال الكثير من
الجهات والمكونات السياسيه منقسمه على
نفسها في مساله البقاء او عدم بقاء القوات
الامريكيه والولايات المتحده تستفيد تحاول
ان تستفيد من هذه الحاله وحاله عدم
الانقسام ومن هنا هي تحاول ان تخلق حاله
من التوازن لكنها فشلت فشلت من خلال يعني
المراهنه على حلفائها في العراق وذهبت
بعيدا باتجاه الكثير من الممارسات التي
استفزت الشارع العراقي بالاضافه لا استفزت
فصائل مقاومه ترى ان وجود هذه القوات يشكل
خطر على العراق وامنه وبالتالي هي تحاول
ان تفرض اجنده الولايات المتحده ونفوذها
على العراق من خلال كثير من الممارسات ومن
هنا اعتقد
انه الولايات المتحده فشلت ولا تستطيع
البقاء اكثر من خصوصا مع العمليات هذه
الاخيره هذه حرب معلنه بشكل واضح من قبل
الاداره الامريكيه على العراق وهي الان
بصدد ان تذهب باتجاهات اكثر صعوبه وقطعا
لن تسكت هذه الفصائل لديها القدره ولديها
الامكانيات وايضا الدعم ما زال مستمر من
قبل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه لهذه الفصائل ذلك
ان اعدم قدره الولايات المتحده على احتواء
هذه الفصال من اعلن تعليقا
العمل او حتى الهجمات سيعود بفعل هذه
الضربات قطعا سوف يعود خصوصا اذا كانت
الاستهدافات مباشره لهذه الفصائل وهذا ما
عبرت عنه هذه
الفصائل بالرد السلبي يعني ليس هنالك
مبادره باستهداف هذه القواعد لمده محدده
هذه المده طبعا وهذا التعليق جاء لم ياتي
تبرعا من هذه الفصائل بقدر ما انه هنالك
وساطه قامت بها الحكومه والكثير من هذه
الجهات لديها علاقات ايضا جيده مع الحكومه
ولديها علاقات مع جهات سياسيه شكلت هذه
الحكومه وبالتالي هم يعملون معا من اجل
يعني يعني ابعاد العراق عن اي مواجهه
مفتوحه ودفع الضرر عن العراق خصوصا انه
الولايات المتحده هي صاحبه النفوذ الاكبر
على الوضع الامني والاقتصاد والسياسي في
العراق والجميع ليسوا بصدد فتح مواجهه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه خصوصا وان
العراق كما ذكرنا يعتبر من ضمن مشاريع
الولايات المتحده في هذه المرحله لكن هم
يريدون ان يخففوا الضرر ويحاولون ان
يقللوا من التدخل والنفوذ الامريكي وتحكم
الاداره الامريكيه بالكثير من المفاصل في
الشان العراقي وهذا ما تسعى اليه هذه
الفصائل لكن الولايات المتحده كما ذكرت
تراهن على قضايا هي بعيده عن الواقع
وعمليات الاخيره عمليات القصف اعتقد انها
غير رادعه ومن خلال ايضا بلق الاهداف ومن
خلال العمليات السابقه ايضا لاحظنا انها
ليست لديها اي معرفه حقيقيه عن هذه
الفصائل وتحركاتها ووجودها ووجودات وانما
تقوم بعمليات قصف عاده ما تستهدف قطعات
للحشد الشعبي وهذه القطعات لا تعمل بقياده
هذه الفصائل وانما لديها قياداتها
المنفصله تماما وهي بامره القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه هذه العمليات تثير الشارع
العراقي وتثير الحكومه وهذا ما لاحظناه من
خلال التنديد الذي لاحظت انه هذا يعتبر
اعتداء على الدوله العراقيه وهو مرفوض
جمله هذه العمليه تسرع باخراج القوات
الامريكيه وهو ورطه حقيقيه للاداره
الامريكيه كما انا اعتقد انه هذه العمليه
هي دعايه انتخابيه لبايدن اراد ان يخفف
الضغط على العمليه الاخيره التي استهدفت
جنوده في الاردن وقدم يعني وجود قتلى
واكثر من 40 من
الجرحى تورد عن مسؤول امني عراقي ان
الغارات الامريكيه استهدفت مخزن سلاح
وثلاثه منازل لاعضاء بكتائب حزب الله
العراقي في الانبار
اذا هي ليست حسب طبعا هذا المسؤول الامني
العراقي لمواقع عسكريه فقط طالت منازل
قيادات ماذا لو وصلت الى مناطق بعيده عن
الحدود اي الى العمق اكثر في في بغداد
مثلا في مناطق اخرى
عراقيه قطعا انا لا استبعد ان تقوم
الولايات المتحده باستهداف مباشر لبعض هذه
الفصائل او منازل هذه الفصائل لكن اقول حت
هذه اللحظه هي لم تقم بذلك واما انه
قيادات يعني قيادات للكتائب في الانبار
استبعد حقيقه ان تكون هنالك منازل لقيادات
نعم ممكن ان تكون قيادات للحجز الشعبي نعم
هنالك الويه للكتائب منتشره في الانبار
لكن هذه الالويه هي الويه للحجز الشعبي
وهي تاتم بامره القائد العام يعني قيادات
الحجز الشعبي لا لم تنخرط باي عمليات
عسكريه استهدفت هذه القواعد و يعني
الهيكليه الاداريه للحشد الشعبي تمنع ولا
تقبل ولا تسمح باي شكل من الاشكال ان
تنخرط فصائل قيادات او مقاتلين للحشد
الشعبي بهذه العمليات لكن لاحظنا انه
هنالك استهداف مستمر من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه والجيش الامريكي لهذه القيادات
ولهذه النقاط العسكريه اما استهداف لمخازن
السلاح هذا لاحظناه ايضا هو تابع للحشد
الشعبي وغير تابع ل لكتائب حزب الله كما
ذكرتم انه او كما ذكروا المراسلون انه
هنالك استهداف لمقر قياده الانبار و يعني
في عكاشات وهو مقار تابع للحشد الشعبي ولا
اعتقد انه توجد فيه قيادات لفصائل
المقاومه في هذا المقر نعم